the Madison team is Patrese experience
most SUVs enough rotors lead uneventful
existences on city streets
she'll be testing both the VW Amarok
with its v6 diesel and the VW cabby all
track both sport VW's 4motion all-wheel
drive so she can see just how off-road
they can really be she starts out in the
Amarok a switch activates the off-road
mode one effect is to change the
throttle response when switching gears
it moves the switching points higher
while the electronic stability program
allows more wheel spin and side slip
angle than it would on city streets but
even with all the technology the drivers
still have to adapt their style to the
surface below the ground is so muddy
here
eNOS feels as if she were driving
through butter she knows in situations
like this she has to keep her foot on
the gas pedal carefully and steadily
feeding the engine to keep the system's
working optimally and prevent the
vehicle from losing traction completely
she can't let it plow up the ground that
would certainly detract from her driving
experience she keeps her foot on the gas
lightly but steadily and if one wheel
should lose traction the thrust goes to
the other 3dt cuffed on the under the
Loretta the v6 diesel unit in this
Amarok with the Highline equipment line
puts out 165 kilowatts an 8-speed
automatic transmission since the 550
Newton meters of maximum torque to the
four wheels so the Amarok can take
inclines up to 45 degrees almost without
effort eNOS explains that switching to
off-road mode also activates the hill
descent control so she can take her foot
off the gas and just hold the steering
wheel straight and the car does the rest
it edges down the slope at a steady
walking speed as confirms that indeed it
works
the Amarok is a product of VW's
commercial vehicles division so is the
caddy
the smallest of VW's utility vehicle
range it's often used commercially in
town as a panel van or by families in
its high roof van body style the all
track version we tested has features
that toughen it up such as a skid plate
and it's all-wheel drive carries it
reliably through ankle deep mud
[Music]
dr. eNOS points out that the Caddy all
tracks increased clearance lets her
venture off road and she surprised at
how well it does with the all-wheel
drive
muddy spots are no problem at all in
town the driver will normally be running
on front-wheel drive to save fuel but in
critical situations and curves or on
slick road surfaces the all-wheel drive
is always at the ready and helps to
enhance safety I stopped the charts good
[Music]
now back in the Amarok yet more
obstacles loom ahead
[Music]
neither mud nor water can keep this
robust pick up from its appointed rounds
[Applause]
he'll never be missus found a vast mud
puddle as a highlight or blow point of
her test drive and it's child's play for
the Amarok the Amarok can handle water
up to 50 centimeters deep but unis
especially likes about the Amarok is
that it brings two worlds together
looking around the interior in
particular the rear seats she feels like
she's in a regular passenger car
it's the cargo space that makes it a
utility vehicle and that has no bearing
on its off-road capabilities speed above
and
[Music]
that's eNOS points out another reason
for picking the Amarok is just to show
off in town with the pickup look but the
Amarok natural habitat is off the road
it's v6 diesel provides enough power and
the 4motion all-wheel drive and other
technological perks give it all it needs
to get from A to B our off-road test put
the caddy all track through its paces
and it proved it's not just another
pretty SUV face even if it has to defer
to real all-terrain errs for the truly
rugged patches when it comes to
reliability off the payment it's
all-wheel drive makes it a match for the
bigger utility vehicles in every sense